listen Sam I was watching the game you
know sports book has multiple games on
Carolina they went down and scored it
was like like 50 it was like seconds
left you know what I mean it was like 50
seconds left or whatever and then I
walked away I left the sports book I'm
like this game's over like it's a wrap
next thing I know
Cleveland comes down kicks a field goal
wins the game I was like oh my God it
was like 60 yards it was a crazy yeah
bro the baddest beat bro I had money
line all I needed for that I just needed
that and I would have cashed my parlay
and that happened brother did did your
week one law since you did your bad beat
was it worse than that
I didn't really have any week one bad
beats man
um makes sense you went forward all
right trying to stand me up Sam I see I
see what you're doing but I had a bad
beat yesterday with Nebraska I was 100
on there now they they got absolutely
destroyed so uh just a horrible bet by
me
hey well we're talking we talked bad
beats let's start the show let's get
right to it Sam the people are here for
a reason I tell them every every week
that you're a sharp and that they should
follow you you just you just literally
told everybody that you went four and
two last week you had a successful week
talk to the people talk to me Sam what
are you rocking with this week
all right man let's do this all right so
first pick
all right I'll just get in front of this
these picks are probably gonna be
controversial the audience is going to
absolutely destroy me and roast me
um but we'll start with Saints plus two
and a half
um I feel like not gonna be popular you
don't want to bet against the goat uh
Tom Brady is incredible but
the bucks bucks offense kind of look a
little shaky last week and I think we're
kind of
uh overrating that performance because I
just think the Dallas Cowboys are
complete poverty I I like the Cowboys in
that game so I was wrong but I I left
that game being like this team sucks the
Bucks have a ton of injuries their line
is completely ravaged by injuries
Godwin's not playing they're going to
the Dome the Saints have really owned
Brady I think they're 4-0 against the
spread and straight up against Brady in
the regular season so they bring
pressure they get in Brady's head give
me the home dog there uh love the Saints
today love that pig Sam love that one we
we know the Saints always play that
Buccaneers team tough you mentioned it
4-0 against Brandon in the last uh 4-0
against the spread against Brady in the
last four match-ups let's go
second pick Sam will love the first one
talk to us about the second one
all right second pick
Panthers plus two I'm going against the
Giants today look
I I'm there's no one that's happier than
me that saquon Barkley is back killing
the league loves saquon Barkley but
Daniel Jones and that receiving Corps is
brutal I I know they won last week but
I'm kind of I'm selling high on this
team the advanced metrics were not super
kind to Daniel Jones last week I I don't
hate this Panthers team uh I think we
get a big McCaffrey week
um I just don't think Daniel Jones
should be favored against anyone right
now
um
say I'm so sorry brother I'm so sorry
yeah
Baker Mayfield it's still the
quarterback
you know I will say this so last when I
was on the Futures show with you I said
I was a that guy and then our good
friend Michael Ritter went back and
clipped out I'm a that guy and then just
posted everywhere and roasted me so this
is this is going to be used the same way
kind of a baker guy I think Baker a
little bounce back I I just don't think
he's as bad as everyone thinks so clip
it out roast me when they lose by 30
points and the Panthers go 3 and 14. I'm
a baker guy relative to everyone
thinking he's the worst quarterback in
the league he's he's not Elite is he
competent
that's that's my take staying back I was
literally screaming screaming from the
top of my lungs at Foxwoods yelling at
Baker Mayfield to make some plays yeah
he just wronged you so you you have you
have bad taste in your mouth
just a little I'm just a little uh
hopefully that bets it's for you I like
it to be honest I agree Daniel Jones
see how he's a favorite uh but anyway
you gave us two you got four more what's
the next one I feel like I'm moving at a
good Pace this week you know in Futures
week you know it's like that was like
preseason for me
um I was getting in the flow now I'm
back I'm moving at a fast pace all right
so if you're out there and you didn't
like my other picks you're gonna really
hate this one this is my
ugly bet of the week it's gonna be super
unpopular everyone's gonna be on the
other side I think you're gonna hate it
too but I am taking the Patriots money
line uh against the Steelers today
um look I'll say this I bet on the
Steelers last week I actually gave out
Steelers humble brag on the future show
and cash
um so you know that that's good for me
but uh I really like this spot for New
England I think that the Steelers
beating the Bengals was a little fluky
they got a ton of turnovers they really
didn't move the ball at all your guy
Mitch trubisky did not move the ball at
all they just basically feasted off
getting turnovers based on their defense
and a huge part of their defense TJ watt
is out this week I think without that
and assuming they don't get five
turnovers again and actually need
trubisky to score I I don't think
they're going to be able to do so
um and I I don't say I I really like
this Patriots team this is more of a
Steelers fade I just think Steelers are
are overvalued
um but like as bad as the Patriots
looked last week they did move the ball
fairly well Mac Jones threw a Red Zone
interception there's a strip sack if
some of those things don't happen I
don't think that score is is as ugly as
it was but I just think the Steelers are
not as good
um as as the market is sort of
indicating so we're fading the Steelers
today I'm sorry Steel Curtain I just
think you fall
is fading the Steelers in the Steel
Curtain today uh that's a that's an
interesting one Sam if if we take a
summary of your pick at the of your
picks right now I see Mac Jones Baker
Mayfield
um
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you back
with my next pick all right you ready
okay okay before before we go before we
go I'm already in I'm already in I've
already seen it I've already no go you
can go I disrupted go hey there there it
is though there it is not Niners minus
nine we're gonna talk about it but
before we talk about it we're doing
something new here my guy my guy Ryan is
uh producer Ryan where where are you bro
what's up guys
I'm in New York I'm in the studio in New
York some someone's got to show up to
the office you know
wow so my guy get the studio
comfy at home he says he said somebody
at the show up hey my guy gets the
studio set up we got we're at home man
where we got remote remote access to to
the live feed and my guys at a studio
producer Roberts I had to go to the
In-laws because I have poverty internet
so I'm not even at home so we both had
to commute okay
oh wow still Sam's commuting but Brian
bro talked to us you're here because
you're here because of the chat bro
you're here to tell us what the people
are talking about
so talk to us what are the people
talking about bro that's right but
before that I have breaking news Sam
you're Carolina plus two is now Panthers
minus one they're now favorite so I
don't know if you're moving let's go you
got a great number let's go so you might
be moving lines there but uh the chat
loves your Saints pick we've got uh
forever Farah saying best pick of the
Day Saints uh SJP 813 saying forget the
points Saints money line uh and then
Mike Ritter jumped in and said uh he's a
big Baker guy so he's not going to clip
that one out
um okay but let me ask you a question I
don't want to disrupt the flow of the
show God but let's do a 30 second
conversation here so like I took the
Saints plus two and a half I know a lot
of people when it's under a field goal
will just take the money line I just
like to have it in case it like mixed up
missed extra points or weird stuff at
the end of the game what quick 15 second
what's your guy's strategy there do you
go for the bigger payout or do you take
the points
when it's plus two and a half I take the
two and a half if it's one and a half or
under anything you know one and a half
pick them obviously right but one and a
half I'll just take the money line
there there it is yeah there it is hey
Ryan you got anything else uh popping
off in the chat bro we got one we got a
rogue comment we've got Anthony dinolte
who just said forget everything that Sam
said I don't care he likes the lock of
the day is Jets plus six and a half
which also happens to be my lock of the
day is that is that your burner is that
your burner cap I'm locked in on the
chat here I don't have time to jump in
here and come out with these people but
I love I love love love love love that
play today so
that's uh and the chat loves the Niners
you I know you're gonna get into that
but Kayvon says Niners roll hey there it
is that's that's transitioning us to
Sam's next pick he already gave us a
little preview of it Sam talk to me he's
talked to the people
why are we leaning Niners mine is not
well first of all really good job by
Ryan transitioning from the last comment
being about the Niners back that was
like that's a plus producing right there
but yeah man I I love the Niners this
week I think rarely in the NFL I think
you get like an emotional letdown spot
but the Seahawks last week basically won
the Super Bowl in their mind like and
every single quote beating Russ and
every single quote from every player and
even Pete Carroll was like this game was
I wanted to win this game more than
anything like they absolutely hate Russ
there um but that's neither here nor
there like going you see this all the
time in college after a team wins a
really big game it's really hard to get
up for the next one
um and and like I said I think the
Seahawks pretty much had their Super
Bowl it this is just a really good spot
for the Niners especially after a loss
and a loss that again we'll get into and
my other pick like that uh that Bears
win was pretty damn flukey in a monsoon
it's just everything happened for the
Bears uh to be okay Sam okay Sam uh I'm
not really listening to everything that
you're you're saying but I I strongly
believe in you and I know that you are a
sharp let's move on to the next one okay
let's move on to the next pick the
Niners minus nine you're locking it in I
don't I I don't know being a Niner fan I
don't even I'm not even going to go
there I'm not gonna go there no bad
vibes we're gonna move on to the next
Pig Sam all right the next I'm glad you
I'm glad you cut me off there because I
was completely confusing myself but I
was right I I I figured it out but uh I
I you know live air all right next pick
going back to uh
uh going back to the Bears well and the
bears being frauds we are taking Packers
minus 10
. that again just to repeat I just said
like that Bears win against uh the 49ers
was just that's not sustainable for you
to win games like that they won because
of the weather and just weird conditions
I'm really not buying this team that
much
um and again on the other side like you
have the Packers coming off a divisional
loss like they're not going to want to
fall to 0-2 so it's it's pretty much the
same philosophy with the Packers and
Niners this week getting these teams off
the loss to a really good
um going against teams that had sort of
flukey uh wins or emotional let down the
Seahawks case
um so I I love the Packers this week I
think they right the ship and Aaron
Rodgers obviously owns
um the uh Chicago Bears yep we know what
Aaron Rodgers does to those Chicago
Bears uh okay Sam last pick of the day
talk to the people talk to me what are
we riding with well it's actually not a
pick today but we don't have a Monday
show so uh I gotta I gotta give this out
now
um but I really like the eagles tomorrow
uh our good friend Michael Ritter is
probably freaking out in the comments
because he is the biggest Kirk Cousins
Stan but again like I I think the
Vikings sort of you know conquered
demons probably isn't the right word but
like they had a huge win last week uh
against the Packers uh now going Monday
Night Football I I really like the spot
for the Eagles I think the Eagles are a
very good team and now the Cowboys
absolutely suck I think they are going
to uh unfortunately for our producer
Ryan roll to an NFC East title but uh I
like this Eagles team they're they're
pretty damn deep I'm a Hertz guy uh and
like I said on the future show I was a
Hertz guy before everyone became a Hertz
guy in the season I'm an OG Jalen hurts
guy so uh I like this I like them this
week I I just think they're a little bit
better than the Vikings
hey Sam I want to uh make a very very
very very important point to everybody
that's watching the show about that game
in particular Kirk Cousins is playing in
a Prime Time game
usually I had that I had that on my
notes I had that on my notes and forgot
to mention it so I'm glad that you did
uh yeah good luck I hope Michael Ritter
is paying attention and and heard that
one because you know how he loves Kirk
Cousins but uh Sam you're six bets bets
they are right there I'll read them all
for you we got Philadelphia money line
Green Bay minus 10. the San Francisco
49ers minus nine New England money line
Carolina Ryan updated us and said the
line move Sam moved the line
it's minus one now uh and I still play
it at minus one I'm still fine with it
at minus one by the way hey well you
caught it at plus two bro so I mean
winter I mean winner winner chicken
dinner to you kudos to you uh but yeah
hopefully they win they are coupled with
a minus one and everybody's walking away
happy uh New Orleans plus two and a half
before we transition to the next segment
I want to tap in with my man producer
Ryan producer Ryan
what's popping off in the comments bro
so another update on the line 49ers are
now minus eight and a half so you're
getting it at a better not as sharp on
that one not a sharp no you got to
balance out also I'm kind of getting you
back there for that Eagles moneyline
pick wouldn't be a show if we weren't
instigating me about Philly but uh we've
got Lou Biz here in the comments who
says he loves Colt's money line today
you guys have a take on that
coach money line
I like it honestly I was talking I was
talking to my buddies yesterday about it
they have to bounce back from last week
and they're playing the Jaguars right
they are playing the Jaguars kind of a
Revenge game for the last game of last
season I was gonna say they have really
I when was can producer Ryan I I don't
know if you're like our our stats guy
but when was I I feel like the Jags have
historically like really beaten the
Colts and I you know if you pulled up
like the Jags were 10-1 against the
Colts in the last five years it wouldn't
surprise me but yeah I don't know I'm
I'm staying away from that game uh I
have a bet on the Colts to win the
division so I really hope they win it
yeah no Michael Pittman today for ND
which I think is is tough but
um I don't know the Jags are fine like I
think they're one of those teams that's
like kind of it's like almost too trendy
right like they're going to be better
than they were last year without Urban
Meyer but they're also not like World
beaters and I think in these first two
weeks they've just kind of been been a
little too popular trendy for for my
eyes so uh stay away for me but uh I
don't hate the pick I I like the Colts I
believe in them yeah so run through a
few here quickly uh a Bollinger does not
like your Niners pick Sam says Lance is
trash uh kingzo Bears will not beat the
Packers I'm zooted Giants win by nine so
he's fading you and Carolina there uh
Cortez chagoya
pronunciation there Packers are trash
now uh he also says Justin Field's gonna
get his first dub in Green Bay so chat's
a little 50 50. you started out hot and
then we kind of faded as the picks came
in so that's not right hey guys it's
it's now time to talk about one of my
favorite bets now last year I was like
teetering it a little bit but this year
I'm all in on the anytime touchdown
score Sam that's easy money bro all you
got to literally think about is one
player that's going to score and then
put your money on them and then like
school hopefully they score I mean and
you get rich guys like yeah you get rich
but it's like guys like Christian
McCaffrey or like you know Alpha Camaro
when he's out there I can name a few but
it's like those guys that usually that
the team offense depends on
it's easy money easy easy money uh
producer Ryan can you pull up those
DraftKings anytime touchdown odds so we
can go through them there they are uh
audience drop your picks make sure you
guys fill up the comments we're gonna
pick a squad ride and get a boost from
our friends over at DraftKings I'll
start this one off Sam I'll start this
one off producer Ryan can you please go
to the 49er game please 49ers versus the
uh they're taking on the Seahawks
they're at home we're scrolling we are
scrolling and we are scrolling
probably will be at the bottom uh Sam
oh do you do you do you do you think you
know where I'm going here uh I think I
do and I I immediately love it but uh uh
Debo are you going Debo
we are going Devo hey when the 49ers get
inside the Red Zone they feed that
mandiba they literally feed him the ball
in multiple ways that's the thing Sam
like we're trying to score a touchdown
here and we want to in any way possible
running throwing or receiving uh Jet
Sweep shoot they might put Debo in the
uh Wildcat who knows they love Devo in
the red zone so I like this pick sit
that minus 130. I'll take that to the
bank Sam talk to me talk to the people
who's your anytime touchdown scorer
today yeah I love that pick and it's
sort of it's kind of along the lines of
what you're thinking there with I want
multiple Avenues to get the touchdown
right so obviously Debo's receiver and
he runs the ball well I'm taking
Christian McCaffrey because he's a
running back but he also catches the
ball a lot too so kind of kind of same
thing along those lines but yeah I think
the Giants uh linebacking court is a
little weak so I think McCaffrey might
do some damage in the air
um all right he's obviously an
incredible player I don't need to say
Christian McCaffrey's really good and I
sneaky think they're going to be I'm
obviously betting the Panthers I think
they're going to be winning and I think
obviously when you're winning when the
game gets tight you run the ball so I I
like McAfee this week correct I mean I
mean Christian McCaffrey I just
mentioned his name like he's almost when
he's out there and he's healthy he's
almost always in the end zone for that
Carolina Panthers team they lean on him
very very very much so uh let's go to
our producer run let's go to producer
Ryan
let's go to the let's go to the chat
what are they talking about in the
comments Ryan
we got Big Mike who loves Curtis Samuel
today honestly Big Mike loves I'm I'm
scrolling through right now big big Mike
loves the commanders today he's got
Curtis Samuel anytime TD he's got Scary
Terry any type TD
um we got Jay Hernandez says Braxton
Barrios TD that's uh those are some
juice dots if you like the Jets today
which I already said I do uh and then
DeJuan Jackson
saquon Barkley we've been talking about
this Giants game and Sam I know you're
on the other side with McCaffrey but
saquan Barkley guys did we like that
I do like saquan Sam did you see saquon
in week one bro he looked at like a man
he is back he hit hey saquan can kind of
be in that that category of of Kamara
McCaffrey when he's healthy the team
leans on him I mean you mentioned Daniel
Jones is his quarterback
so I I don't disagree about saquon but
Sam
I'm strong on my Depot break yeah no I
like that I I like saquan I think I look
I think Daniel Jones not very good
they're receiving core not very good I
think they relied on sequan a ton last
week
um I think they're gonna have to do it
pretty much every game this year to have
a chance so uh obviously I like the
Panthers won the game I like McCaffrey
to score but I think Saigon is going to
get a ton of looks today so I I like the
pick for him to score
Sam likes it uh
Ryan what are we going with bro what are
the people saying are are they what are
they saying are we going saycon are we
going Debo are we going McCaffrey you
tell us what are the people saying what
is a squad ride well the people have a
lot of picks in here but it seems like
we are galvanizing around saquon Barkley
and the New York Giants today
is that is that what we're leaning that
is where we're leaning that's where the
chats lean in here no bias no bias
because I know you're in New York right
and I know you're probably like 30
minutes or so away from the stadium or
whatever no bias you're sure that that's
what the people's rocking with Melissa
Greg I am a Cowboys fan my rule of thumb
is bet against the Giants so I wish I
didn't have to say this but we are going
with saquan Barkley we are rocking would
say Quan Barkley as the squad ride pick
and you know how we do it here
we got that thing boosted you already
know it's it we boosted it up from minus
145 to plus 120 and they're only doing
that for us here BR betting in the
draftking squad is doing it for us so
shout out to them Sam
it's now time
it's now time baby it is now time
for the parlay of the week man I'm so
excited hey Sam
earlier in the week earlier in the week
bro uh be our bed we posted a we posted
a clip or we posted a a story not a
story I'm sorry we posted a clip of a
bet
and it was a 15 leg I believe
um and it resulted in I believe it was
minus 106 that was where the odds right
or was it plus 106.
something like that but uh it was
something like that yeah something like
that it was plus 106. and I just thought
that that was like crazy crazy crazy
but it was very interesting Sam it
actually engaged pretty well on our page
it had a lot of comments I mean I even
commented in there and a lot of our fans
commented so
you know what I was like you know let me
um
he put my cape on my winners only cape
on him my winner is only uh my Winner's
only cap on and try to figure out how we
can hit one of these parlays uh
so you want to get right to it Sam
let's do it uh I also just love what the
what they've called it below the Greg's
there's no way this loses unless a
meteor crashes into the Earth parlay is
is maybe uh my favorite thing ever so I
love that hey that's that a if this
there's no way this losing Sam like I
I've been in a lab I've been in the lab
but like I don't think you understand
bro I've been in the lab producer Max
had me send him this parlay like 15
times so I had to think about it 15
times Sam so like I've been in a lab
about this and we're gonna get right to
it first off Sam we're Mac actually can
we
producer Ryan producer Ryan are you
still there he is um their producer Ryan
is there
let's start off producer Ryan with uh
the Miami Dolphins
alternate spread
let's go to the alternate spread if we
can
and then go all the way down brother all
the way down until we can't know more
plus 17 lock that one in yes sir that's
that's that's one
Sam now we're you you talked about the
Bears you talked about the Bears right
let's go to the Bears producer Ryan
let's go to the Bears because we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna talk about
this game uh will this game be close
maybe maybe not
um but will it be a blowout
I don't think so so go to the Bears and
go all the way down producer Ryan so you
can't go no more and click that that's
that's leg number two let's move on
the next leg of the parlay
the next leg of the parlay
the Vikings Monday night game Vikings
Eagles
there it is
go to the Viking side Ryan and then go
all the way down all the way down this
entire parlay is just Ryan scroll all
the way down all the way down Sam we are
trying to get as much as many points as
we can with this bar light uh all right
we locked in the Vikings is that three
Ryan that is three
how you feeling about it
I'm feeling like I'm gonna be scrolling
a lot hey we'll go to Houston Texas
Houston we're Houston we might have a
problem with this parlay
Ryan you already know what to do all the
way down
go to Old spread and scroll all the way
down all the way down plus 24 lock that
in all right let's move on we got the
Texans Ryan Falcons they're playing the
Rams in LA
click it and then we're going to scroll
all the way down and uh
it should be around 20 something 20 some
points we getting with those Falcons and
I actually absolutely love that number
plus 24 and there it is uh you just
gotta pray that we just gotta pray that
there's no blowouts all week because uh
that that just that's our strategy this
week I I am that's how that's that's
literally how you play these like the
NFL is a competitive lead we talked
about it we're just connecting the dots
of the show we talked about it earlier
the NFL is a competitive league so they
don't want any blowouts if if some if
the Cowboys get blown out 77-0 it's
going to be on on on radio talk on ESPN
Jerry Jones is going to be going crazy
they don't want that in an NFL so guess
what we're gonna bet like that producer
Ryan bills I need the bills
and then for this one producer Ryan
you're not even gonna have to scroll all
the way down nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope oh go to the top
there it is there it is yes sir
yes producer Ryan Buffalo Bills plus two
and a half no way they're losing that
game Sam you know it's a great pilot you
know it's a great parlay when like
you're shocked that a leg is is as low
as minus 630. like that was that was the
lowest odds we got it's minus 6 30. I
love this this is hitting me
hey hey I'm telling you I'm telling you
Sam a producer Ryan Cincinnati Bengals
Cincinnati Bengals Cowboys money line
no sir
all the way down producer Ryan all the
way down please oh there it is this is a
lock
yeah there's no way yeah this is this is
not losing very lucky uh
after the Bengals let's go to the
commanders there they are right there
facing those Detroit Lions Ryan you know
what to do brother just go ahead and go
ahead and take a scroll all the way down
and click that
I need a t-shirt that just says producer
Ryan scroll all the way down we got to
make some custom merch because that is
that this is my favorite thing
let's move on because I got two more
legs for you guys Tampa Bay
Tampa Bay let me guess
wait Sam Sam I need your help here Sam
okay all right I got Buccaneers Plus 11.
you're you're rocking with the Saints
should we ride with the Saints on this
one
let's just I want you because this is
your no way this loses unless a meteor
crash in Earth Parliament I want you to
trust your gut and your gut was bucks
plus 11. uh Great Value at minus 740. I
I love it
Sam said trust the gut so that's what
we're going to do producer Ryan you
already know what to do click the bucks
plus 11 because we are locking that one
in
in for the final and last leg the
Indianapolis Colts ride
Indianapolis Colts
they're taking all those exciters I'm so
excited to see what the final payout of
this this is the last leg so I just want
to see like did we did we are we still
in plus territory or did we get all the
way to like minus 120 I'm very we might
we might end up in plus territory which
is which is which is good I mean if you
want money and you want to win
right you already know what to do click
that brother uh and then let us know let
us know what those odds are
plus 231 what's 231. Greg look at that
can we show the entire parlay I have an
inside source on the app team uh that a
lot of people in the comments section uh
are asking to see the entire ticket
because the people people want to roll
with Greg yeah the chat is trying to
produce producer Ryan right now and they
want the whole ticket
so this is what we got
hey Ryan instead of a fast scroll give
him a slow scroll you know how sir get
your get your screen grabs ready here we
go yeah when you when you're running all
the way down you had to go fast but now
we want to slow it down yeah Ryan I'm so
sorry go to the top let me read it to
the people yes sir while you scroll here
we go guys from the top Miami Dolphins
plus 17 absolutely love that one Chicago
Bears plus 24 Minnesota Vikings plus 15.
Houston Texans plus 24. the Atlanta
Falcons plus 24. Buffalo Bills plus two
and a half Cincinnati Bengals plus five
the Washington commanders plus 13 and a
half Tampa Bay Bucks plus 11 and
wrapping it up for us are the
Indianapolis Colts plus 10
hey get on DraftKings and lock it in
yourself like it's right there in front
of you it's plus 231 those are good odds
Sam talk to me Ryan talk to me how y'all
feeling about the parlay
I just love it man I I I I love the name
I love The Vibes like I I just
absolutely love it um and let's just
let's just hope a meteor doesn't crash
into the Earth and and this bet caches
but uh this is this is one of my
favorite things ever
let's hope a meteor does not crash until
they hurt Ryan
you got any words brother
I listen for Vibes I love this uh it's
unfortunate that you know the Bengals
leg is in there but let's just hope the
bills don't lose that's kind of really
the only one right where it's like that
that's the closest thing we have to a
money line so I love it
I love it though Ryan likes it Sam likes
it I love it you guys make sure you guys
get on DraftKings and go bet it now
let's get to my next favorite bet Sam
this is a new one early win
the gist of this one is you can place a
money line bet on any team and if at any
point your team goes up 10 points you
win even if your team lose it they just
have to go up 10 points and you will win
it's as easy as that Sam
I know you've been uh in the lab
thinking of a team that you think is
going to go up 10 which way are you
leaning here
yeah well I also should say this promo
cash for both teams in the Thursday
night game because the Chargers and
Chiefs both went up seven uh so like
that that's incredible if you can get
both money lines cashed out but uh but
yeah man I use this promo with my Pat's
bet so I took Pat's money line and they
go up 10 I'm cashing early and I love
that so I'm I'm sticking with my pets uh
who are who are you rolling with
Sam uh I think I'm gonna ride with the
team from Buffalo I'm gonna ride with
the Buffalo Bills here I think they're
gonna go up early and often and I don't
know if the Titans are going to keep up
with scoring with them so
10 points and see them going to go get
that and uh
writing riding hosting and coasting Sam
to Victory make sure you guys get on DK
and get your early bet win in Sam all
right here we go over or under we're
gonna play a little game we're gonna
play a little game uh each
actually I'm just going to get right to
it Sam I'm going to name some players
and we're going to go over or under
their uh their their prop bet I guess so
let's just get right to it bro because
I'm confusing myself already there it is
over or under saquan Barkley 75 rushing
yards
Sam I'll start it off oh
love it I'm going over we we already
talked about it there it is we already
talked about it my man is the Bell Cal
up uh in New York I think they're going
to lean on saquon heavy in this game
go ahead Sam you can talk about it a
little bit I like it no I think we
should rapid fire these
um again I'm also I'm trying to do what
the app comments are doing which is uh
producer Ryan's job
um but yeah let's rapid fire these I'm
going over I said it I think they're
going to give safe on the ball a lot
rapid fire Tom Brady over under one and
a half passing touchdowns he's playing
he's playing the uh the the the the the
the Saints so I'm going under
Saints own Brady under you got a nice
little value there I think it's like
plus 150 on the under love it they
definitely own Brady let's check in with
producer Ryan producer Ryan what are the
comments talking about right now
are they filling our over and under
fakes uh quick breaking news again we're
breaking news left to right on this show
uh say I'm not great for your Saints
pick Alvin Kamara is out today we knew
that though I knew that yeah it's
official it's official but uh the
comments Greg they're loving you we've
got DeJuan Jackson saying he's riding
with you uh specco says yo Greg Brady
quits today Saints can easily win this
game by 13. uh Bama boy says Bucks
versus Saints over the chat has gotten
completely off topic the chat just wants
to talk about what they want to talk
about they have no takes on these props
but uh we got takes left and right in
here so uh we've got let's see let's see
can I say something yeah if people are
riding with Greg's parlay DM it to be
our betting of your ticket
um because when it cashes we're all
gonna post all the winning tickets so if
you're riding with the parliament damn
it to Greg DM it to be our betting uh
don't DM it to me or producer Ryan but
damn it to Greg or BR betting hey I say
we hit
let's go to Vegas next month guys or
something why not do it
let's move on let's move on producer
Ryan you could be here for this this
this one we're going rapid fire Mitchell
trubisky over under a half interceptions
go ahead right way over he's going over
way over
I'm going over
Greg we've been aligned on every pick I
love this hey hey you know you know how
we do Sam you know we're aligned hey
let's move on Joe Mixon over under
longest Rush 15 and a half yards oh
that's a tough one
yeah I didn't even know what to do with
this one
um that's just like uh over under the
longest rush I have you know crazy bet
um but I said over here I think he hit
it like 60 of games last year so that
was really my only thinking there so
Joe Mixon he is he does break quite a
few you just mentioned but
um
I don't know if I'm putting my money on
that anyways let's move on let's move on
Devonte Adams over under seven and a
half reception that's easy that is ABS
that's not even the question we know
that they're going oh oh Brian Ryan's
going under you have to talk to us why
are you going under Ryan today's hunter
run for a legacy game today is the day
into the chat love that love that I got
Hunter info on my fantasy team and he
didn't really do anything week one so I
need him to uh step it up Ryan talk to
us about those comments though are they
on topic or are they all over the place
they're getting on topic I want to win
says over for the longest rush for Mixon
uh he also likes the over for [ __ ] uh
interceptions uh wavy baby uh is really
trying to get my attention he likes the
Jets money line like I said just the
points come on guys uh we've got uh over
receptions for Devonte uh Big Mike says
20 plus yard run for mixing today I'm
locking it in
all right
like it there it is there it is hey guys
I guarantee you guys there was lots
given in this show it was it's up to you
guys to fade or follow
Sam Ryan I think it's time for us to get
on the body here and put some bets in
and uh get ready for this NFL Sunday
so for great my name is Greg guy for
Greg Ivory for Sam Richmond and my man
producer Ryan we are Audi peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]